in an exclusive CBS News interview
attorney general william bar highlights
why he opened an investigation to the
origins of russia investigation bar says
there is evidence that makes him believe
that senior government officials may
have acted improperly to authorize
surveillance of president Trump's 2016
campaign and he says that led to the
spying on the campaign
critics say Barr is being too loyal to
the president Jan Crawford is in
Anchorage Alaska traveling with the
Attorney General Jan how is Barr
responding to complaints about his work
well the Attorney General he wouldn't
really talk specifics about what he is
seeing that led him to open that
investigation but he said he is not
swayed by criticism and he won't back
off doing what he thinks is right you're
only the second Attorney General in
history who served twice I think the
first one was back in 1850 right I mean
you're an establishment figure in a way
you've had a long career in Washington
but you're working for a man who's not
establishment and some of his tweets
about officials and the rule of law how
do you react when you see those are you
on Twitter do you read his tweets no I'm
not on Twitter and every once in a while
a tweet is brought to my attention but
my experience with the president is we
have a good professional working
relationship we talk to each other and
if he has something to say to me I
figure he'll tell me directly I don't
look to tweets for I don't look at them
as directives or as official
communications with with the department
but when you came into this job I mean
you had a good reputation on the right
and on the left you're now someone who
has you know accused of protecting the
president enabling the president lying
to Congress did you expect that coming
in well in a way I did expect it yeah
because I realized we live in a crazy
hyper partisan period of time
and I knew that it would only be a
matter of time if I was behaving
responsibly and calling them as I see
them that I'd be attacked because
nowadays people don't care about the
merits or the substance they only care
about who it helps you know who benefits
whether my side benefits or the other
side benefits everything is gauged by
politics and as I say that's
antithetical to the way the department
runs and any Attorney General in this
period is going to end up losing a lot
of political capital and I realized that
and that's one of the reasons that I
ultimately was persuaded that maybe I
should take it on because I think at my
stage in life it really doesn't make any
difference into your career I'm at the
end of my career I've you know it's a
reputation that you've worked your whole
life on though yeah but everyone dies
and I'm not you know you know I don't
believe in the homeric idea that you
know immortality comes by you know
having odds on the backs you over the
centuries you know so you don't regret
taking the job no in many ways I'd
rather be back to my old life but I
think that I love the Department of
Justice I love the FBI I think it's
important that we not in in this period
of intense partisan feeling destroy our
institutions I think one of the ironies
today is that people are saying that
it's President Trump
that's shredding our institutions I
really see no evidence of that from my
perspective the idea of resisting a
democratically elected president and
basically throwing everything Hanneman
and you know really changing the norms
on the grounds that we have to stop this
president that's where the shredding of
our of our norms and our institutions is
occurring now throughout our
conversation there was one theme kind of
that really emerged I mean Marcis his
action since he took office including
clearing the president of obstruction
when the Special Counsel declined to do
so as really standing up for the rule of
law
anthony jan what did the Attorney
General tell you about why he decided to
summarize the special counsels report
rather than release it when he first
received it well I mean that with some
news there I was surprised by some
things he talked about on that as well I
mean that was not the plan
he had asked the special counsels office
over a period of weeks and was led to
believe that the specialist counsel's
office was working to identify that
sensitive grand jury material that could
not be released by law to the public or
to Congress so he expected the report
when he got it from the special counsel
to have that material identified so that
he could quickly turn it around and
release it pretty much in its entirety
when they got the report at the
Department of Justice
none of that material is identified to
his surprise but he said the public
wouldn't wait weeks while they figured
out what that was he had to get
something out quickly people work you
know camping out the Justice Department
the media intelligence officials were
wildly speculating as he put so he
released that summary he said it was
never intended to go in the nooks and
crannies of the report while they work
to identify that grand jury information
but that was not the plan and if he'd
gotten what he thought he was getting
from the outset that four page summary
wouldn't have been necessary all right
Jen thank you you can hear more of Jan's
interview with attorney general Barr on
today's CBS this morning podcast and
Monday Jan goes with Barr to a remote
Alaskan native village to learn about
the unique challenges in those sparsely
populated communities